[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody
welcome to the stream sponsored by
samsung i'm cam robinson and i'm joined
by jayanne from blackgirlgamers hey hey
dan how are you doing i'm good i'm good
how are you i'm very well i'm excited
actually because we are here today
because the next generation of gaming
has obviously arrived we've got the
playstation 5 and we've got the xbox
series x
right here this stream is all about
pairing
our next generation console with some
next generation coaches obviously yes
but also a next generation
tv that is capable of helping us like
squeeze all the power and all the
functionality out of these consoles
and that's what we have here so this
monster
that we're playing on today is um it's
65
inches and apparently has 33 million
pixels that's a lot of people i know
it's called the q 800 t
from samsung and uh i think you should
tell us about the gamer playing jam
because i've been talking a lot since
this stream so we're going to play some
dirt 5 and i'm super excited to play
on the q800t because i've been asking
this question
everywhere to all of my friends asking
you know i've got the next gen
what do i pair it with so i'm really
excited to see how this like just
blows me away with just everything i'm
really excited to see the frame rate all
of that stuff so
cool yeah and the reason why we actually
chosen dirt 5 is because it's one of the
few games right now
which can do 4k 120p which is really
exciting so
that's what we're going to have to go at
today so why don't you literally drive
us away
jan when you go so okay racing games are
not much stronger no i've heard you
i've heard you're very good no no i
don't know who told you that because
that's a lie
um but i'm gonna look forward to shining
this i have um actually got it at home
as well
so i haven't uh well the good news is i
was playing a few hours earlier and
if you go to the career mode we've
unlocked we've unlocked a few cars
um and uh a few kind of different races
to choose from so
you know maybe you want to go to italy
or china oh let's do china take me on a
world tour where are we going to china
okay
yes now oh so the the great thing that
i've already discovered about
dirt 5 is you can create monstrosities
of vehicles so
this is the omp car i made or i have no
idea what omp is going to ask you what
does that mean
this is me trying to create the most
hideous black and white car i could i
mean i think i like it
you can either just drive this away or
you can make your own if you if you
select it now you'll see
you have the option to create your own
it's up to you but uh
i think we should have a competition
later to create the worst i do like the
i'm not gonna lie i i kind of yeah it's
unique yeah
yeah take my car it's absolutely fine
but um just don't
destroy it like i definitely did earlier
yeah yeah sure
sure but the important thing of course
is to see
our horrendous cars in you know
next generation visuals ooh now
the i think there's a really cool thing
about dirt 5. if you haven't played it
yet by the way is
there are a number of graphics modes
within the game
um i think we've got it set to just the
standard which is like
prioritizing resolution okay um but the
great thing about this tv
is whether or not whichever of the three
modes you choose right so you've got the
resolution mode
you've got the um kind of texture
quality mode i forget what they call it
image the image image quality
that's the word and then there also has
frame rate mode
which is prioritizing that 120 p frames
now the cool thing about this tv is no
matter what mode you
choose it can it can show which is
really great so if you're doing
4k no problem this tv is 8k
okay that's what you've got all right
we're off and i'm in last place
that's right you start from the back and
then you you know where you have to go
i love them in your soul sense of
security as well sorry from the bottom
now we're here
and we're still at one that's right it's
it's a race
i was gonna say it's not a racetrack
yeah but it's literally what it is yeah
um it's sorry you've got two laps two
whole laps to catch up
okay oh
that's just yeah if all else just use
violence
but well you see actually you just
complete one of your challenges because
uh
it says jump and trade paint which i
guess is a nice way of saying
crash into your fellow racers yeah
exactly
now earlier i was trying this and i
could not nail a drift over tape
life with me i thought i was drifting
but i may have just been sliding
but what's the difference between
drifting and sliding i'm not sure i
think it's just vernacular
or style yeah maybe just when you're
drifting you look cool when you're
sliding you are out of control
get up get out of the way interesting
driving tactic yeah
um you know this is
how we do it from from my side so we
will do some
some multiplayer later on but i wanted
to just put you under pressure for us
and also give you a chance to get a few
races under your belt because i
i unfairly had an advantage playing
earlier how long have you been playing
for it you're playing this um before uh
oh only a few hours but i've managed
because there's so many different modes
i've managed to do so one of these one
of the more like
rally cross modes and one where i was in
like some sort of a dump truck almost or
something
so i've had a bit of a buried experience
um
but literally every map i've done it's i
think they must have
had this new tech like in the in the
game engine that allowed for this
this lovely um like water effect because
it seems to be everywhere
yeah i'm just looking at the mud in the
ground and it just looks so
clean you know today is actually my
first time
getting my hands on or i say my hands
more my eyes on an xbox series x oh
yeah i've played ps5 a few times but
this is actually today's my first day
because
i was one of those people who tried to
pre-order well i was a bit lazy about
trying to pre-order oh there we go
i missed them all yeah oh what did i
just okay
oh yeah because i find i'm usually quite
uh
probably annoyingly smug about like not
being an early adopter yeah
like early adopters kind of sometimes
get a raw deal
yeah but then this time i totally regret
not just just diving in because i feel a
bit left behind hey
but you're not left behind though not
that good
yeah it's the op car it's all about yeah
yeah exactly
awesome that was really good considering
you say you don't play racing games that
was that's a pretty good show
you know natural talent just you know
so you can choose a different mode now i
i'd like this about the game they're at
the end they really like make a big deal
of like everyone's celebrating the car
yeah
are they all the drivers they're putting
the car
i thought it was just the car it was
just like yes good job
well done car and you got a reward now i
did
technically purchase from the store just
so we can level up a bit quicker okay
everything you can get
i i don't know exactly how it works but
i think it gives us more xp but what
that more money but what that means is
we can unlock more cars as we go
nice so okay
is that so the redeemer i don't have
that one yet we can go to new york
okay and a sub-zero i guess like uh it's
gonna be like a winter race
now if you want you can unlock a new car
i think you should okay
um so i like the
the paint finish on this it's kind of
like a matte
metallic well what kind of car do you
normally drive you don't want to know
is it going to be in the game definitely
not
but i'm kind of feeling this one it's
kind of a ford
ford fiesta yeah okay look at the
spinners all right let's go with that
one
can i oh you can lock it yeah yeah let's
go done
and are you gonna go in this kind of
matte gray or yeah
yeah yeah you want it it looks clean
keep it classic it looks clean okay
let's go for it
no i've not done this one yet oh you're
literally racing on ice oh look how nice
so you picked it he's stressing me out
don't worry ice is famous for its
traction you'll be fine yeah yeah no
problem
oh god okay well we've got we got the
we've got the um commentary in game
tournament turned off so we're
so we're not hearing that but uh yeah
there was definitely someone giving you
some
some probably needed uh advice on how to
drive on the ice but yeah
we'll be fine
okay okay show us what you got
don't know if you want to see that
because this is not going to be pretty
i'm like i'm not even pressing go oh my
god
you just give them a heads up hey it
worked last time you started to
put them back in for a second all right
i believe in here okay cool
okay okay i've noticed this tactic
you've got where
you use the other cars to break yes then
like plow into the side of there 100
percent just using their momentum yes
it's fine it's good it's um
you know she's work they say work smart
not hard
exactly you do pretty well actually
considering that's your first time
driving on ice yeah in the middle of the
pack
it's not bad at all uh we on
okay
[Music]
now one of the things uh actually just
to tell you a bit more about
the q800t and uh it's actually something
where
we're really noticing right now i think
in this studio setup
is what this tv has which is really cool
is this anti
reflection cutting and i don't know if
you're like me but
often i noticed this recently when i was
playing the last of us in like a really
dark area
yeah i was playing the game and it was
really really dark and i was also
playing at a friend's
on a smaller tv and we were like
crunched around
and this was pretty this was like
pre-lockdown or in that little gap in
between lockdown but anyway
we were in his house and i just had like
all these reflections i'm not a great
like viewing angle and in dark areas
that just doesn't really work
and we'll think we'll see that when we
do some some night drives what the cv
has
is this like anti-reflection coating
which uh is these really tiny like
layers of filter
yeah that um that's that kind of reflect
away or stop the light reflecting on
off the surface so it means in a dark
studio like this we're not going to see
the reflection of the lights
and it also means if you're driving even
if you were to move over to the other
end of that couch there i reckon you get
a really great viewing angle
that's so good so for multiplayer later
when we're both playing that'll be
helpful
and if we were able to get four people
socially distanced from this studio we
couldn't we could cram everyone around
and uh all able to see which is cool and
actually i think we'll also notice
because this thing is oh did they not
even let you finish um
so yeah that happened wow okay
well why don't we why don't we uh how
can we both play this one yeah yeah
that's fine
do some multiplayer i love the um
what you're saying about the uh people
being um
obviously for your social distance and
yeah could all play
but um i think that's great because it's
such a great size to actually see what
you're because you're doing
just a show i'm gonna i'm gonna race you
from here i can see this so
you're gonna brag is that well i'm i'm
only gonna brag if i'm gonna win
okay which is probably not gonna happen
let's let's go to brazil is that the
brazilian one yeah let's see the
brazilian one yeah
yeah the statue oh actually you need to
go you need to let me yeah
okay so i think that is
uh no uh if i do why is
am i already in no uh if you go back one
more or is that is that already better
okay you know what i need to do turn on
the controller that probably helped
there we go i think i might win then
yeah
yeah it's a good start from me okay cool
over to you i'm ready
so okay so whichever you like yeah free
play
take us to brazil now let's see
i'll just hope i can race the hideous
car okay here we go
oh no okay uh do we have monies
i don't know if we have the monies here
uh no sadly not okay i'll tell you what
why do we both can we both create our
hideous car now are we
are we locked into this i have special
options
and uh i don't know if you have them but
can you can you spend the
experience and things to lock these no
no no okay okay i think you're stuck in
the
silver as well i'm not the best silver
win
absolutely rally raid
i thought even more rally rate is all
right i'll move back over here
there we go okay
it's i know it is raining i swear every
everybody everybody is raining
or ice all right bring it all right here
we go bring it on
the bottom i'm i'm actually going this
time i'm actually leaving
well i thought i was top screen for some
reason which was a horrendous error oh
my word this is
so bad all right well i think uh
you're definitely winning this okay here
we go facing the right direction come on
cam
not controller not on facing the wrong
direction this is everything okay
oh oh i'm not the one to talk this car
feels
uh stupidly powerful i uh
so what happened was is like there we go
oh no i get it no
i see you crashing let me leave let me
see you all right okay here we go no
there's no here we go i'm
gonna rush here we go uh i was gonna
drive on the inside of the car but
actually that's so much harder
so god this is what is this car
i think i think the difference here is
we've selected a car where you need to
use the brake
problem and my driving style was all
about not using the brake
in real life uh no you'll be glad to
know not real life
not not really but well actually you
never know
i'm gaining on you slide no
oh no thanks for the corner assist there
we go so you're using my car as a brake
exactly i learned that from the master
yeah
oh no oh what did you
just spawn you back in like marry
yeah we are um not doing very well all
our opponents
and they're the the really embarrassing
thing is if we get lapped that's what we
must avoid
um i'm going to try and find okay
yeah working using the brake is kind of
working for me okay wow
are we spawning again i don't know why
these keep this keeps happening to me
so i think the handbrake is on is on b
by the way
oh right perfect that helps for the kind
of drifting around corners which i've
still not really managed to ah
there we go let's see oh my wow the side
of my car is not looking good
and neither is the front oh well
oh i can just imagine everyone watching
is like come on guys
you can drive better please all right
fine fine i'll try
try better promise you i can drive in
real life i promise you i have my
license
one of the really cool things i've not
actually done this yet one of the cool
things about dirt is you can um
because this is a 24 you can literally
choose what time of day you do the
racing right oh yeah we should do a
night race
yeah we can do that but apparently we
can also do is an
all-day race where basically you set the
game
you set the speed of the day-night cycle
so you can do like an entire
live an entire day during one like four
minute race or something
cool so you can see all the seasons oh
wow it's really dark in this tunnel i
don't even know where you
are in the tunnel yep uh
oh here we go oh i just i just used this
oh there's the tunnel okay i'm not sorry
you're not that far behind me yeah yeah
yeah
watch out actually i'm aware you think
you're slightly gaining on me i've lost
my i see
you oh yeah i've definitely lost some
time in
um
oh okay whoa handbrake is definitely
helpful finish eleven oh you finished
um one thing i am gonna just just
explain to everyone watching at home
that's just which is kind of confusing
because
we're in this great situation right
we've got the xbox series x
which can do 4k 120 in this game we're
on the samsung q800t which can also do
well up to 8k and 120
but what we're actually seeing in the
studio is actually
1080p 60. now the reason is because in
order to
show the game to everyone watching in
the stream at home
we have to get it into our our vision
mixing software
and our vision mixing hardware and
unfortunately we did we did a bunch of
research
spoke to people across all different
like broadcasting industries
the piece of equipment doesn't exist
that can handle 4k 120. it just just
doesn't exist wow
so um and obviously the signal has to go
into our kit
before it then come back to the tv so
what we did do though before we played
is we sat down
and plugged the xbox straight into this
tv played some 120 frames
um you know 120 hertz and it was it was
really awesome
the difference between 60 and 120 is
definitely
definitely visible it's hard to kind of
quantify how would you describe it like
i don't i just i didn't i just felt like
it was so much
more clean i don't know how to describe
it it was just clean it was reactive it
was just so
yeah i don't know how to describe it but
i noticed when we was um
the difference from when we switched
yeah and it was just such a an
improvement you felt i felt more
immersed watching it as well
um while playing it just feels like
like i know in reality what's happening
is is our inputs are our
or we're getting we're able to we're
able to react twice as quickly because
um you know it's 120 frames every second
versus 60 frames every second so
there is more opportunity for us to
react and register you know an input
and then to see the result um so yeah
and i know obviously
120 frames is is not really anything in
new in terms of um in terms of like
uh esports players sorry yes 100 percent
but everything yeah counter strike is
always talking about you
need your high frame rates yeah you see
and everything but to be able to like
sit at home
and play your console 4k 120 that's or
8k
120 when it's possible you'd never see
me wear this tv
um but that's that's again the other
reason why we
you know we wanted to feature this tv
with uh
the export series x is because it you're
kind of future proofing yourself
because because right now i know we've
all seen it on you know the side of the
side of the boxes of the consoles and
all the adverts and everything
they can do 8k right yeah but can they
do 8k right now
no no we don't have anything for it do
we well no it's not kind of been enabled
yet and there's no games i guess i mean
i'm not an expert as to why it's not
been enabled but there's no games that
utilize it
but the cool thing is when they do this
tv
will be able to set up okay already
really cool and until then it can
actually i mean if you jump back into a
game in fact if we both select a car
then we might be able to
yeah see what we're doing um but yeah
until then what it's doing now which is
really cool is it's
doing what's called uh q led upscaling
so if you were if you're at home and
you're playing a 4k
game you know on this tv like we were
earlier yeah um what the tv is doing is
it's using
ai and something called deep learning
algorithms which is a phrase that i
really like
wow and what it's doing is it's looking
at every single image
of every frame and it's it's working out
where the extra pixels need to go it's
filling in edges it's filling in
textures
and it's creating like an 8k image from
that 4k using ai
which is really cool so wow even though
the consoles aren't doing 8k
yet if you plug your series x into this
tv
you can still kind of see 8k before it's
here so what you're telling me is this
is like the irobot of tvs
that's that's exactly what it says it's
exactly word for word yeah
so um yeah it's uh it's a shame that
right now in the stream obviously we're
not seeing that but it was great to be
able to do that earlier and the xbox
is it running at 4k as well or is it
yeah
awesome yeah the xbox is absolutely um
okay let's see if we can do a bit better
this time
no oh i'm actually with the computer i'm
actually with the computer control
drivers here this is real brag don't
worry bragging doesn't look good can
i think it's because this is a little
dusty this level oh no there's still
there's still rain
there's still of course there is
what's the last racing game you played
chad you think
if i'm being honest it's probably mario
mario kart honestly
um that's the only racing game i've
touched in the last couple of years
honestly um because i play with my
siblings
um sometimes especially specifically
mario kart is age friendly for everyone
yeah yeah so but what i love about
america
is and simon i guess similar in this
game is but there is skill involved
you know of course there's so much skill
involved i like learning
gaming in general requires quick
reaction of mind
and problem-solving ability like it's
not something where you just
throw it on and um you know it doesn't
improve you sorry who's this guy some
random computer guys just facing the
wrong way he's my ally okay
you just don't judge sorry i just
smashed them in the wall
yeah i think the last racing game i
played uh before this
this this is an older game but i played
it and when it came was re-released was
um do you ever play burnout paradise
no i played i played burnout but not
paradise oh right yeah paradise is the
one where it's like an open world city
um so yeah i played loads of that so in
theory it should just come back to me
i just i just use the walls
i'm sorry yeah i gotta say i'm enjoying
these um
what are these dirt buggy things more
than the the aston martin that was just
yeah that's the most too much get too
much power for me if i'm honest
i'm not sure i quite had the skills yet
for that one we can work ourselves up to
that i
uh i'm trying oh no he's overtaking me
okay
right never mind then maybe he's lapping
me i don't know
i feel really disappointed in my
performance today
oh i'm good oh i'm you're not you know
what you know what we're not last
you're 11 in front of 12 and i'm 9th at
the 12th come on 12
out of 12. that's how you speak um we
can do this
i mean i know you're trying to encourage
me
i believe in you oh well i'm 10th man
i said that's you i see crashing into
that
driving like a maniac oh
come on come on look
i can't oh no no no no
come on get out the way if this is oh no
we still got another lap i was like i
thought that was going to be the
the final i see we have the same
technology
we're into the same skill of driving
uh-oh
gta score no the rubbish guy returned
yes
oh what's this guy's name oh my god he's
so far away i can't even read his name
anymore
come on come on jay beat cam that's all
i want to do
here we go here we go this is serious
now okay i'm actually more into being
the computer guy in front of me he's my
nemesis
i am suffering with this game honestly
oh well good news we still got a whole
lap to go i think
no really oh yeah yeah final lap here we
go
this is a long one yes come on okay okay
nice that was a nice i saw that that was
good
come on come on i think i've got it i
think i've got it cam oh what's that
what's this
what's the key what's the key using the
break no
coming off the acceleration just tapping
it a little bit ah okay okay
so not just constantly holding the
accelerator so
oh maybe you actually
oh oh no
computer guy here what's his name that
is his computer
i think his name is tio you stick no
he's gonna overtake his bro
oh damn it wow okay
you're holding me up nope you just
pushed me into some rocks i did
no such thing you did this is worn out
blasphemy
all right well maybe if i drive inside
the colander oh no that's not going to
help at all
this guy's wearing is he wearing
bandages no just big gloves
like a mummy costume or something okay
uh
oh here we go come on yeah i always like
like the idea of playing racing games in
this view but my word it is hard
yeah i i really respect people who can
play racing games well and like
just not crashing to walls and use them
as a stop because
that's all i've done i'm i'm gaining you
though no you're not
well maybe i'm not home break
handbrake was a mistake final push no
yes yes
you can no i think i'm gonna drive a
little like
crash captain what she finished yeah
that's a good one it was oh wait no it
was
lucy was the driver who i think you kept
overtaking me lucy the sheriff why did i
read that as tio clearly i'm going crazy
okay right that was that was good um
what we could also do
yeah is although there's only two of us
in here we actually have
two other game pads through with seb and
sam
in the uh in the control room next door
so those guys want to join us for some
four-player multiplayer we can see how
the tv handles four-way split screen
yeah let's go which
should be great because it is huge
that's something else
collecting all your money yeah of course
you have to worship the car and
get your money of course um
cool so if we just jump back to the main
menu
and if you guys through there oh yeah is
that oh it's so weird
is that them it's a ghost yeah oh ready
set we go too
and then ruby say we go three they are
so quick i know
these guys are actually good at their
jobs yeah
you've got cameron out here fumbling and
trying to figure out how to do things
the wrong way controllers are off all
right so over to you arcade i guess
okay um where should we take them
where in the world uh you choose okay
okay um
yeah it's nice because i'm not be able
to travel anywhere this year let's go to
south africa i've never been so africa
that's always been on my list me too
yeah i have a friend who lives out there
who runs like a a game reserve but like
a small one
which is all about rewilding the reserve
oh and i really want to go visit him
oh exactly so the story can it goes
nowhere i've never been there i mean
check it back maybe i will in the future
just to segue into something completely
rather than
random as well i've been playing planet
zoo uh
yeah just because you reminded me of
zoos reserves
i i've what was planned i've never
played it what's that planet yeah
it's kind of like if you've ever played
a roller
um coaster tycoon or all right oh yeah
okay so it's like a sim
build yes super complicated um
that's going to really help you in the
dirt race we're about today yeah
transferable skills absolutely okay now
let's see how seven and sam do
now okay so where am i okay i'm top left
perfect okay
i'm oh yeah which one am i
i think i'm tough right yeah i'm top
right okay cool i am i think we all have
to go the same car by the way guys
we're all broke we have no farmers in
the account
yeah oh we should change can we change
the color of our cars no
okay i guess we're all the same car
that's gonna be fun
at least we'll know who the computer
people are actually
are there gonna be air drivers i wonder
what if it's just me the four of us oh
yeah that's true
i mean i think it's the same setting so
yeah this looks like is this some sort
of like drag race track
or not drag rate um like stock car track
like just going around and around or
i know you're speaking words but i don't
know what they mean
what's the stock race track i don't know
i think i made it up i mean like what i
mean
is it's just inside okay here we go it's
like an actual course inside the stadium
right
okay i understood that's what i meant
thank you words i said
okay uh whenever you're ready oh i've
got about that
all right all right so i have no idea
who's who i love your wife
said which one are you
[Applause]
said bottom right sam's bottom left okay
cool
um okay we can tell i just drove into
one back one of you
i think it's me and you're pushing hello
you're pushing me along
you gotta say so bad definitely enjoying
the sheer
size of this tv right now yeah like
to be able to play four players split
screen and actually still have some sort
of decency
100 such a treat i remember just
when i was young and playing with my
siblings just squinting
or sitting you sit right in front of
that little square yeah
oh jade why don't you break okay i don't
alarm you but i'm in sixth
it's very exciting it's technically
middle of the pack oh
fifth we've got
okay oh we're doing better i guess we've
had more practice than seven sam
and seb is also technically running the
live stream and racing a car
which is very impressive playing on the
job that's
smart i know so i think we can we can
forgive seb but sam's got no excuse come
on sam
uh oh oh i think i'm in the lead no how
did you get in the lead
it was very brief i briefly played with
the lead and there was 15 minutes of
fame
yep it was worth it i don't know what
i'm doing honestly i just
okay this guy's name is bandit he cannot
be allowed to win
oh well oh no no no no no no
i'm facing the wrong way and you're
creating a car
i don't know where to go and the mighty
have fallen where am i going
oh no they've just all right okay it's a
race between us humans now
the machines have won
i was at dizzying highs for a moment you
caused such a commotion in that tunnel
honestly i am now lost because of you
i like to have an impact better or for
worse
oop
all right so if i'm an 11 and you're in
12
then that is either okay that's sam in
front of me
all right sam you're going down sir and
by down i mean
behind me slightly that's the plan oh
he's he's he's doing the vault whoa
what happened there we drove so well
that the xbox has crashed
okay well uh i guess we just quit the
game
that's really weird is it definitely
grass yep i can hear you
my controls i'm really having a bit
right now well there you go
our driving was so bad the xbox decided
it didn't want to live anymore
and it broke the game okay so let's quit
that and come back in
but the good thing about this next
generation of consoles is that it does
load fast
yes now um while we load in if you have
a look at the screen
behind us here we go um you can see some
some lovely shots we got off the tv
earlier and in fact these tvs behind us
i should mention
not the same as the one we're actually
playing on these are the q90t
which basically has all the same
functionality as as the
800 t we've been talking about but it's
4k
and these are 55 inch um but yeah you
can see they
look fantastic as well okay the game is
ready again
we're back in pretty sleek let's go
shall we oh oh who are you which brady
sebi girl would you like to be as
the the first one first one okay
okay and let's see if we can all join in
again yeah uh i'll go ready say we go
one
all right guys feel free to jump in okay
we have a two
and we have a three
all right okay where do you want to take
us this time so south africa was not a
good cause
yeah i think we may have flown too far
maybe italy let's try closer to home
okay oh i don't think there's multiple
multiple tracks per
location yeah so i want to do you know
where do you know where any of these
places are
how well do you know italy i don't know
i've been to uh
milan i've been to um
venice and sardinia did anyone oh did
any of them look like this
oh i like the aqueducts can we can we
erase on the aqueducts this one
yeah okay nice i don't know
i actually don't know if these are real
places or maybe that's why
i'm just so let's go and find out okay
great
cars for everybody oh it's the aston
martin again okay be prepared to fly
into orbit
okay let's hope it doesn't crash this
time that would be nice
uh yeah i'm not sure that didn't happen
we were testing it earlier
i do think it was probably because we
were driving so bad
okay so afternoon race bit of snow
on the ground it looks like you should
do a night race next as well good time
yeah yeah okay so i'm guessing i'm still
top-notch oh my god
it's already starting i love her with
this like
fleet of gray cars at the back like some
sort of mob
like mafia drivers or something okay
oh yeah i think you're oh no yeah okay
using the walls oh my god
oh my god i've done it again oh my god
oh oh
i could never do probably these cars
once you face the wrong way
it's very difficult to get back the
right way and then
the steering is so loose on this car
like you really have to be very gentle
yeah yeah definitely and i think this is
why
i'm not a professional i don't even know
where i'm going
are you just stationary just like i
don't want to play anymore
stuck in the wall oh my god
oh okay i'm gaining on somebody i assume
it's one of us but i could be wrong
this is really really hard it's like so
much harder than the other modes
i don't know who this is oh this is
already civil go in front of me i don't
know which one it is
is it me it's you it's me can't you tell
by the driving i mean it could have been
any of us
oh you still in front of me
[Laughter]
oh oh that's a corner see i knew it was
you know oh my god
i knew what have you done to me i knew
it was a corner because you plowed
straight into the wall
so you're using me for experimentation
exactly exactly to find out how the
track actually looks can i go straight
here no i can't
okay well now you can now you can see
from from my terrible driving
so okay using the brake
hey here we go oh like a corner so loose
okay
okay this is looking better how are
those guys doing ninth and seven all
right oh
i think it's sam sam's in seventh i
think
good job sam they're living their lives
truly i know
where i want to be it's all the uh it's
you know it's the pressure
it's the pressure right i was gonna say
we are doing the hard work
normally i'm an excellent driver just
oh is it left yeah okay to the right
yeah
see this track doesn't have a lot of the
um the warning signs where you just
literally slap
into the wall oh tunnel oh
okay oh so you're not that far in front
of me no the tunnel has warning signs
oh god i literally was going to plot to
overtake you and i just slapped it
all the time how's that going for you oh
no no okay
so after the tunnel there's a there's a
very tight right
there see i'm nice learn from my mistake
actually also there's a there's a map on
the screen
oh my gosh there really is a map there's
a mini map little oh
okay that is so much easier to know like
where i'm actually going
i'm struggling with the um understeer
oversteer i'm not sure
both let's say both of those you know
when you uh correct you're steering and
you create yeah
and throwing like when you skid on like
oh you know what really and truly i
should never have any hopes of being any
type of racer in my life
okay yeah well oh no i'm sorry i'm on my
side
well if it helps seb is intense
sam's really the only one who is doing
us justice here come on sam i'm really
just
oh come on sam don't let that guy in
front of you no sam's not facing the
wrong way
[Laughter]
letting down the team oh well yep
uh we are now in the last four positions
oh well
you know birds of a feather exactly i
blame the grey car
that's why honestly it's camouflaging
with the road and i don't know which is
which i'm sorry
that's that's my problem as well all
right i'm gonna go i'm gonna go inside
the car now oh it's crashed again
uh all right i guess uh dirt doesn't
love four player right now for some
reason
um let's uh let's quit the game
okay so thanks der oh wait sorry i keep
i'm actually this is just me feeling it
quitting the game there we go
okay um okay so the game will not let us
play
we're that bad that's uh that's an
achievement
so maybe we should do is go back to some
uh some single player because okay
what we've not done yet is um really
gone through the career mode
yeah that's true yeah so maybe if you
want to implement through the career
mode buy a few more cars
we'll just find the right car for us
then we'll be good yeah
that's sure that's the theory
all right gear up jay let's get this
let's get better
can't be slapping into one of them
training now it's real
right exactly all right let's look again
okay
korea so we which one did you do before
do you remember uh oh you did the ice
one didn't you yeah that was the new
that was the new york one um yeah
because we did that now you've unlocked
this what's this uh are you going back
to brazil
all right to unlock the next one oh yeah
cool
okay what's this one below that all
right
oh arizona right okay how do you know
which oh it's a sprint one okay right
what's what i think that means yeah
it would be like more of a rude race as
it were
okay are you gonna throw down some coin
or no you don't have enough never mind
oh wow you just called me broke live on
stream
i mean well you got 44 and i think the
cheapest there was like 70 000 or
something
but your car is made of gold so that's
pretty cool well you know yeah that's
pretty good i have to hustle in this
game a little bit more then
improve okay
uh i've always wanted to go to brazil
have you been to brazil i've not no
no i feel like one cap i know i have
been other places
i feel like it's one of the good things
about this game right now during
lockdown it can take us on a world tour
while we're stuck
in england all the time all right i need
all right
i need encouragement cam i need tickets
i believe in you okay
i need tip encouragement i can do tips
i'm not so sure oh jesus
okay this is not that bad handling this
car
much better than aston martin it's going
good
i think nice yeah use them to slow you
down when needed
look at that straight into forest keep
it up
i think it's the gold car yeah it's the
gold it's it's
the pizzazz yeah yeah using the wall
again jay come on
nice okay all night no no you're fine
you're still middle packed it's good
it's good
you've got this you know this
oh god follow them sorry matt
sorry maybe i feel so bad i know
she just used he was in the wrong place
it was nice
[Music]
but hey well i'm in second place it
works you know
don't knock it
why don't you drool up the side of this
car
look at that though first place yeah
there you go there we go
oh it's a that's a really tight one
nailed it
okay oh oversteer right there in fact
you've done all your um your challenges
you've got a
oh snap you little you've done your
total air time
challenge you've uh shouldn't paint and
you've gone over 50 miles in the timer
for long enough it's been really great
you're really great
go away there we go where am i going
uh left left left
[Music]
i loved i think you were just showing
like i'm so skilled i can look at the
side of my car while i drive
uh uh you know what i'm gonna say yes
okay well ready set he goes in the lead
good job
[Music]
how dare you right at the finish line
bro
you were robbed i wasn't lucky i'm upset
in your car
no i'm upset second is good
i feel robbed okay okay i'll i'll have a
go yeah yeah
you can make fun of me when i crash okay
so you have to get better than second
then second is good i know i'm gonna
really struggle although you have
absolutely ruined your beautiful trophy
car
it's uh well look at that damage look at
all that rep
there you go i earned her some monies
you earned us
a lot of money i can buy i think i can
buy a car now
you buy me things okay uh did i
unlock the next course as well you did
so apparently aj is telling us something
that's what we're after the big headline
oh aj you speak too fast
um okay but they don't just let anyone
in not if uh okay well
okay thanks aj fish i'm busy okay so
um main events are at the end of a
chapter all right so we're getting close
to another chapter
ah don't even have stamps we don't we
don't have enough stamps let's do
how do you understand this i don't know
driving well i guess
let's give it a go oh let's give up on
that dream oh my word what is this
i guess i'm going to drive this guy um
it's a
jupiter hawk it's a 410 boat
garbage truck but it's also like a slide
for fun
slide in the middle uh yeah
um it's gonna be very difficult rear
wheel drive
crane oh it's got a c for handling and
an s for performance this is gonna be
um interesting good luck sorry it's
hilarious
are these real are these real cars i've
never seen these in my life before
i'm finding this safe these are real
real vehicles
why not good no windscreen because why
would i want that
but why so you've got no wind stream
something you need but you've got this
necessary yeah an unnecessary fun slide
yeah okay good
um this is gonna be interesting second
is gonna be difficult uh
i'm gonna try this from the in-car view
because i am a fan oh you know i didn't
try that
yeah i think i know someone can't get
the sensation to speed when you're in
the
oh wow look at that who needs glass and
you've got
you've got metal bars you're like i mean
you're on the you're on the floor
you're in some sort of high-speed prison
that hand struggling
took me out this is this is really
difficult the thing is
you're on a course where there's dust
flying in your face so the one course
where you need a windscreen
i think i'm assuming i'm wearing a
helmet with a visor that's like it's the
only thing i can do hopefully ooh that
was lovely uh
lovely um lens flare there
oh yeah beautiful oh i unlocked the
achievements i achieved something
apparently i was drifting i just thought
i was driving
who's you i love the air yeah they're
looking well
like you said the lens flare but the
dust and the um
the shadows and the sun yeah really
really cool
i mean that's one of the great things
about having you know 4k and 8k tv
like this is you can you're going to get
to see all the details if there is a
detail to be seen on screen
you're going to get it oh there we go
take that wall
i never liked you uh how am i doing jan
um yes
oh yeah you asked me questions am i
gonna get lapped is it
okay no i don't see them at the back the
car that's i think this
i don't think this view is why this is
not working okay
you're right i don't wonder look at this
thing
this is definitely better you're driving
oh no it's not it's worse i'm backwards
no i'm being left
fine you can play again it's all yours
did you get any stamps not any good ones
i don't know this car is taking me out
completely
yeah oh dear
oh dear oh well i didn't position
uh high enough but i still got given
money who would pay for that
who would pay to see me drive like that
the manufacturers of the car
yeah maybe testing the strength of the
vehicle
yeah exactly how much punishment can it
take well somehow i've unlocked
a land rush race for you in china oh
okay you can take
let's try that return of the omp car
do it let's go but the good thing about
the amp car
on on this particular tv is it's it's
it's you know the color
the coloring is black and white and
perfect segue for this tv because
it's got something called um it's really
dynamic contrast
of okay basically you know how all tvs
these days have a game mode yeah well
what the q800t
and also the q9t as well they have
something called gamemode plus
which is really cool because when you
turn it on it just activates a whole
bunch of features within the tv
that samsung know you're gonna want if
you're playing games oh okay so it's
it's the like
the standard things of you know like low
um input lag and things like that
but it also enables it's um it's kind of
high frame rate so you can do the 120
hertz 120p that we've talked about
but it's also um this kind of dynamic
contrast so because the tv is incredibly
bright
um it enables the dynamic contrast so
you can really get more details
in the shadows as well um so it just
it kind of because you don't listen if
you're watching tv you don't necessarily
want a super contrasty look but for
gaming it can look really really great
um so that enables as well so it's like
a bigger range
of shades exactly it's because of the
the kind of these tiny quantum dots that
make up the panel they
they're really really bright um so you
get this the huge difference between
your highlights and your shadows
so yeah that that both helps with giving
you really dynamic contrast
it also gives the tv this thing called
100
color volume which is which is again
another phrase that i need to work into
my vernacular
and what that means is because of this
huge range
of of of um shades that the tv can
create you can do that in the color
spectrum as well
and 100 is in relation to
dci p3 cinematic color range and
this tv can create all the colors in
that range um
all down to these like very special tiny
dots to make up the panel
and um all of this is part of the game
enhancer plus
which uh which is just inside all these
tvs that's awesome
yeah like you said you set you up for
not just 4k but 8k when everything's
enabled and you've got all that tech
what's really good
because like even if a tv had all these
things but the fact that it's wrapped
into one mode means
if you want to play games all you need
to do boom game mode on
and you know that it's configured itself
for gaming that's what i really like
because otherwise
you might be going through tv and like
messing with all the moves
changing the contrast to the sharpness
i've done that and it just takes forever
and you can and then you want to watch
you know a tv like tv or a movie or
whatever and then you have to
reconfigure everything back
and yeah that's that's the great thing
about gaming how to plus you just turn
it on
and you're ready to go i love that they
thought of that yeah convenient journey
because for so until game mode you know
like people never seem to really think
about
people who want to play games in them
and then game world's good but this is
like the next step
and you are doing oh pretty well i was
until i actually just keep talking about
this yeah because you're driving really
well
it's actually squaring me on okay okay
i shall i shall continue oh god see
now come on yeah this is the car
equivalent of a zebra
i love it yeah it's because it's the
only texture that i had unlocked
[Laughter]
so yeah you're doing really well come on
second the handling is
good except get up there we go
oh let's go come on push him out the way
he's in first night
these these cars seem really slow
compared to that
before i think it's just the difference
in
the oh my god oh no bad turn that's
going to ruin everything
yeah you say it's a fine line for
success and failure
in this in this game it's a fine
question this game of life but also it's
a game come on you can do it
come on but once it gets up to the top
screen it's quite
yeah it starts to go yeah you're really
traveling now
see the problem was there was no car
there for you to like i know
i really am a codependent driver yeah
it's just teamwork they just don't know
they're on your team exactly
okay through the puddle i gotta say
i do love the water effects yeah i know
it's in every single level but it looks
great
they really do really nice oh yeah we
should definitely play around with the
um might race next
yeah yeah i guess we need to unlock one
oh we don't have enough stamps because
we are poor drivers hey
me i know i know yes we are yesterday in
fact if anything
you're the one who's gone you're in
first
oh i was cam i need you to talk more
technically
again helping me out you know what i can
i can i missed something
when i was talking about the game
enhancer plus i forgot to also mention
the tv um has is ready for hdmi 2.1
which you know you're able to get with
your new xbox or your ps5
and so yeah that you need that in order
to
view 8k you need that cable and that
connection i should say
so that's also also part of the gaming
house plus
ah fourth it does help when i talk about
tv
that's interesting just need to know all
right can i redeem myself yeah and get
the night made
okay i'll try and i'll try and do a
night race
yeah that was that oh you were
unfortunate to miss out on the podium
but
that was good that's very good i needed
the worship but they're
yeah the driver you see the air the
driver is in there
really yeah there you are oh okay yeah
he's falling asleep he's like nothing is
not in the head
okay where to next game
the um 2.1 that's something i've just
been talking to all my friends about oh
yeah just trying to find out
again what's the screen what wanted to
what can we find for the next gen
um so it's really good that it uses that
because i just know like i need
something
next for so i can just get the
experience
and feel immersed in it i'm so into
graphics visuals when it comes to games
and that's probably why i don't play a
lot of retro games with you well if
you're into visuals
just wait and see what car i'm gonna
create here oh
okay so this is the the custom car
creator in the game i think we should do
a competition to try and see you can
create the ugliest car in the shortest
period of time ugly scott okay so i'm
just going to
very quickly create something hideous
okay i'm going to do the timing here
oh i'm going to see if i can unlock some
more textures can i lock this
sure okay there we go i'll add that
texture there you move it
uh and then this color oop
really gonna appreciate seeing this on
the giant tv
there it's in blue oh this is not even
looking that bad come on
i was gonna say it's not looking very so
talented it's actually looking good
okay here we go now i can read it let's
get some clashing colors
oh nope oh what we're done uh oh yeah
that's that's not very nice yeah for
that one
okay and then oh texturize that one too
there we go it's like some sort of
mutated
tortoise or something oh no oh i've
ruined it
well no that's all right that's still
ugly yeah it's not as ugly as i want it
to be there we go okay that'll do
done okay that was what less than a
minute well
maybe maybe about a yeah maybe let's say
that let's say two minutes
and then next race see if you can make
something worse oh my god
i'm gonna take this but i'm naturally
like i've naturally got style
so okay okay like that is pretty hideous
oh i forgot about that the back looks
nice goes to the back i actually like
the back you know what i'm actually
gonna that looks nice
can i go back into it no i forgot you
can also add decals as well okay
and i unlocked a weightlifting carrot
which i was made to put on the car but i
think
obviously oh weight lifting yeah yeah
that uh yeah maybe you can add that one
or actually we've probably got enough
money that we can unlock a bunch more
okay so ultra cross modern rally
italy here we go
take this guy you can do it
it's a pretty ugly car on the left as
well i know
everyone went for an ugly car and tried
to say thank get out of the way you
there you go oh wow i'm trying your
aggressive driving style it's working
for me
so i just lose my bonnet no yeah no one
else did someone else who's bought it
eyes on the road cam eyes on the road
okay don't watch anyone else's car i'm
determined
to do at least as good as you second i
came four
well no but but you're about your
perspective oh my god
that's what i gotta do you're second now
yeah so you've already done it
easy all you do is stay in this place
way to make me feel good
well done ken but i don't think this is
going to last though is it
you yeah you will probably will i'm
racing underneath underneath these
aqueducts that's awesome
yeah it's really beautiful yeah the
light the light is really nice it's
really good
and even like i feel like you can see
the dust still in the air
yeah it's so nice it's got a hazy look
oh whoops sorry sorry
i'm ruining the aesthetics never
happened messy driving
okay yeah yeah i'm gaining on you other
car
oh underneath oh god sparks what
special effect i know they really went
out on this challenge
oh i was trying to you trying to use
your tactic and use him as like a break
that didn't work
he saw the move yeah he saw it he's like
he's like i know your game
okay here we go second all right yeah
yeah nice
oh see if you can get it first yeah
okay you got it you've got it oh pass
them on the outside you don't have the
let's use your technique
using the jam method it works smash them
in the bowl
yes well done awesome oh no slash him
again
yes turn him around yay i'm not
aggressive
that's good sportsmanship oh no he's too
clever damn it
use him again no you see like he was
ready
he's gonna use you don't know he's too
well behaved
he's uh these ai drivers are very nice
they play by the rules yeah
[Music]
oh well we've gotta take all quickly no
yeah
we're not like
[Music]
okay all right i got it you got it chip
is back just
that's it yeah just knock him out there
you go guys
yes that's it come on quick
left hand got it you broke a bit hard
there maybe maybe not moving oh yeah
position first for 10 seconds yes that's
literally really close dave i know
i really want no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no don't you dare don't you dare
open
the wall with you sir that's it yes
you've got it oh that wasn't it oh no
no another last one i thought that was
the end
okay you've got this you've got this
don't look back
i'll show you his glass just on the wall
he won't try that
again he's trying it again
i can't believe he's trying he won't try
it again he's trying it again
i can't believe it i'm
[Music]
all sure oh no oh thank you oh i mean
i'm blinded but it's beautiful
yeah very nice
it's like the sun's moving position in
the sky i think
yeah it is i think it is because um like
you said
they have the the day-to-night cycle
then
yeah and there's some of it in your face
the first lap
like that no i think it's definitely got
more blinding damage
right that's all right it's all right
it's all right uh he thought he was in
the lead but i had the racing line there
he brought a friend hopefully they can
fight over
oh no you got it you've got it i know
not long left now i know this corner
is uh get tight big breaking here and
then accelerate out of it don't over
steer and then that's right is it all
right
it's kind of all right he's coming for
you
quick quick quick quick yep keep going
come on you've got it come on
ugly car wins the race well dad the
thing is it's less ugly when it's
covered in mud
yeah you don't really get to appreciate
it's it's ugliness well done cat all
right thank you
that was that was impressive we're
getting there i won't match that
getting better learning um glory to the
call
yeah exactly all praise this time earned
how much money i'm not sure i'm not
figured out what the rep
oh maybe the rep is what allows us to
unlock other races in this year oh
okay okay oh we got some um some rewards
as well
nice some delivery rewards
which is going to help you make your
ugly car perfect
it's always well any any game with
customization mode i'm always
whoops and we straight in there trying
to create something awful
oh okay we've unlocked a new bit
nice so what are we doing here oh we can
sign sponsors
make more money okay sorry ump move over
we need new sponsors okay and then
code codemaster is right oh do you have
to choose one is that what's happening
there we go okay uh oh nice
and you've now got the ultra king sorry
ultra cross uh
you gonna i'm not gonna know how to
pronounce that
forest shanxi long
i think this might be night time as well
oh okay now if you want you've got
126 000 uh
pink dollars dirt dollars to spend
i'm loving this color honestly that is
nice
but oh oh god this car reminds me of the
night the cause warranty
yeah ford cosworth
[Music]
my memories oh subaru impreza
the blue one yeah you like the blue one
i like the blue one
it's got a handling so oh my gold rims
go on
and who needs that many headlights
nobody needs that many hairs like a
spider
all right pimp my ride let's go just
hold a to
spend all the money sorry cam we're now
uh are you gonna make it horrendous
let's go yes
so yeah it takes a little bit of getting
used to but inside
so you go inside pattern one okay or no
sorry use them
uh rb and lb to be able to move between
the different layers yeah and then you
can add textures
and you can unlock a bunch of them there
i think
okay so
what what kind of theme are you going
for with your design then
uh what are your what's your inspiration
crushing colors flashing colors okay
that's always a good one that's always a
good one
so you've got a kind of a kind of deep
blue
with uh what's that like an arctic
a cyan kind of color yeah with stripes
it's pretty hideous
it's almost a mint green actually oh
yeah there's my weight lifting carrot
you see
how do i move it oh there you go yeah so
you can put him on the side oh you can
make him bigger
i don't know that that's something
i'm so annoyed why didn't i know that
that's so good
i think we need is that broccoli or is
that a tree it could be either you know
broccoli is basically tiny like
miniature trees so
um are you making giant yeah let's go
eat your veggies kids i already
love this car oops let's see um you can
keep going yeah
oh you can add another one too more
decals see what we got delivery color
let's try this
so if you move to uh if you go to a
different
no we're not high enough level to do
that unfortunately
yeah well while you are creating this um
incredible car
one actually one of the things i should
have i should really mention is uh
we talked about the q800t and how um you
know how that pairs with the xbox but
what i haven't mentioned is what we've
been hearing
and that's true yeah one of the really
cool things about uh this setup we got
here is
i don't know if you can show this save
on the camera as oh if i pointed it
right there we've got the q 900t sound
bar
which pairs really really well so you
know we're getting next generation
visuals but also
our ears are getting some next
generation as well which is great and um
what this what this tv also has uh is
you can
if you plug it if you sorry if you
connect it to the soundbar usually when
you connect a soundbar to a tv
um the output just swaps so it goes like
no longer the tv output now we're going
to use a soundbar
but what the soundbar does um is they
synchronize together
and actually it will utilize speakers on
both so you just get you get a more
immersive kind of sound experience oh
that is
horrible perfect looks like someone's
murdered your car it looks like you've
driven in
to a whole group of animals and now
there's blood all over your car
that is horrendous well done and then
and then talked about veggies
this is great do i do safe and quick i
think i think you should i'm quite
i'm quite impressed with your awful
creation it took you know
that's not my normal style it took a lot
to get back that is
really something and in the headlights
it's so much better than the original
you know what i'm a convert i kind of
love it
yeah all right well you're not supposed
to love it show how it dries it's so bad
it's good you know it's like a nicholas
cage movie it's so bad
it's good i mean i love nicolas cage so
i really didn't say that
do we know what type of race this is no
you said it was night
where did you get that oh i thought it
looked like it might be night no i was
wrong
it's dusk it's tough it's dusty it's
almost hopefully it goes
it might become nice yeah that's true
that's true come on veggie car let's go
okay all right it really does look
like blood it does
how did you i don't even know how you
did that but it drives
really well wait how dare you
use my tricks against me yeah these guys
are crafty
[Music]
oh um
come on i've got this i've got this you
got this i've got this
no come on you're no longer no longer in
the podium
[Music]
yes okay so these three green cars
oh shortcut straight into the corner
maybe not a shortcut oh my gosh it looks
like a shortcut look looking good get
out my way
no how dare you
[Music]
i'm okay all right we've got this we've
got this cam we've got this
all right i believe i believe faith
give me tech talk come on all right okay
of course yes you drive you drive better
with the tech i do i do okay but you're
in second so i
need some eminently okay so uh i'll i'll
remind you then
that uh you are currently in first place
because of the power of the q800t
maybe that you were playing on yes there
you go um it's
65 inches which is why it's so huge
and over that over the space step panel
is 33 million pixels jam
and you were still impressed this is
actually working i told you okay okay
okay um well i think it's probably
you're probably doing better because we
are actually having our
our image upscaled so if you remember
because of technicality streaming
this we're actually seeing 1080p
upscaled to 4k
um but if we were going straight from
the xbox into this tv
we'd be seeing 4k 120 upscale to 8k
which would be even better um look at
this you're
definitely okay keep talking right um
what else can i tell you about what
happens um
what else oh whoa
doing very well yes come on get out come
on don't try
and pass me no
[Music]
nice very good
[Music]
so uh uh maybe a bit of a reminder about
the
game enhancer plus you did well last
month yeah you did
so i'm really excited about that so okay
well just remind you
we've had we've got that enabled what
it's currently doing for you to improve
although not that you need something
much improvement oh no i shouldn't get
that oh see
what it did to improve your driving is
obviously the the low
latency the low input lag um but game
enhancement plus also adds the the
variable variable refresh rate
and freesync that's the really cool
thing where it matches
i may have forgot to mention this before
yes well done and we were in night mode
very good yeah it didn't change but uh
the reason why he did so well is because
as the xbox was trying to hit that solid
frame rate
uh probably of of 60p in this mode um
if it ever deviated from 60p because
this tv
has that um the free sync
and uh the vrr the variable refresh rate
it matches
whatever frame rate it's getting from
the console which is really cool no
drops
if you're exactly no drops so no screen
tear
and if if it does drop you won't notice
it because it
you know it matches the the change in
frame rate to the the change in the
refresher on the tv
so and that's why you won because of
game
enhancer plus there wasn't anything to
do with your skills you're welcome
thanks okay so where to next um what's
my next drive
you should the next one oh look you've
got a choice of two here you go uh
you can choose from me you sure yeah i
trust you all right are you taking me
we are gonna go to the himalaya the snow
looks good
i think i would love to see the snow on
the tv okay
uh um yeah we spent all our money so
oh no we can we can we spent our money
oh actually look we've got other cars we
can take i love that yellow one
that is awesome you want this one no the
um oh this one yeah
um do you think that's going to be good
in the mountains
because i do like
okay it's gonna go really well it was
like expecting the answer
snow racing i think that strange yellow
car
absolutely i can just imagine you flying
off the mountain
oh dear oh this is going to be a huge
mistake
well seeing as you you keep asking me if
i've been places how have you ever been
to nepal jam
no i've come to i've been to china
oh you have oh i have yeah i went to
hangzhou
um where abouts in china is that so
that's like near the
i think if i'm remembering correctly
it's near like southeast china
and i caught a train to shanghai um so
it's around that area but it's like a
bit of a distance it was really cool
um hong kong's like a university town
were you either studying or were you
just no i was visiting a friend at the
time
um for like three weeks so go out there
learned a little bit of mandarin um very
good
this is after i graduated uni so it was
also like a trip for myself
it's experience life oh no
oh thank you friends
yeah this car is a this was a huge
mistake if you choose this
it's like driving a bumblebee it's
really strange
it is like driving an insect yeah it's
pretty speedy though
i kind of like it's got no traction i
like how ludicrous it is look at me
it doesn't have much time calm down car
calm down stay
on the on the snow see they've gone for
the you know the one that was lime green
they're more heavier
slightly heavier vehicles oh this does
not like the water not even slightly
i think i think you might i think it's
like a micro machine
i'm no expert but that looks like a wall
uh
[Music]
oh no yeah this card doesn't drift very
well yeah the traction is very very uh
basically it's got one gear i know it's
got three gears look it's only got three
gears
i'm already maxing out third gear
oh come on
uh come on i can catch him i can catch
him
[Music]
come on come on buddy i have a
semi-faith in you okay well i have okay
so what's a realistic goal here not
being last
right yes not being lost okay i think i
might be able to do that yes
come on stupid weird car
that's it that's it that's it control it
yes go and cam
see see your problem it's really speedy
yeah but then if you make a mistake it
it when you lose that traction
well you know what they say with great
power that's how i feel with this car
absolutely come on buddy you're not
doing too bad it's getting there
in mind you can definitely catch i think
you definitely can catch up with the
next period
yeah okay i think so i have them in my
sights
[Music]
no almost oh look that guy's driving one
oh yeah he's having he's he's he's
really confused
he's really controlled he's making me
look bad i thought i was
driving a ridiculous choice of car yeah
yeah
okay i feel sorry you've got this cam
come on you've got this yes crash about
the way you room for one and only be one
and apparently it's him he's the one
oh no come on bumblebee i've ruined it
okay the jam technique oh i missed him i
missed him
the technique needs some finessing you
need years of experience
i don't have the sheer regression to do
it
didn't quite work need more raw power
okay
out of the way you've got it you've got
it tactical braking yep
tactical braking nice nice nice should
you talk about the sliding you've got
one
tactical jumping yes okay no
oh yes yes yes
there is only one it's me you're sick
now awesome don't put the pressure on me
sorry
[Laughter]
oh there's still another left that means
you can catch up
this is really stressful this is now the
most important thing in my life push
that incept to the limit i must
i must finish more than six come on
you can catch that one up you can catch
that one yeah yeah we're getting
starting to
learn the ways of the insect car he says
it goes crazy there is a subtlety to it
you know
it's like horse whispering you gotta you
gotta whisper your way to this car
and now i understand i don't wanna see
you whispering to a car car
getting there um okay here we go
no no no that's taking that corner wrong
it's all right
it's all right it's recovering it's
another one you've got this oh no no oh
okay that is another no that's a
different one
i hope that's a different one that's the
difference like this one if i'm not the
fastest insect
in the hall of nepal i'll be really
upset oh no
sorry it's all right calm down it's okay
you've got this come on just don't let
him out
i don't know if i'm doing this right
this is definitely one of those cards
where i'm just constantly holding you
can tell how competitive i am i'm not
even playing the game and i'm clenching
myself
oh thanks i appreciate that it's
supportive oh no
no no no no no not you no no
he said yes no no come on beat up speed
up speed up speed
oh that
i can't believe it eight seven oh it's
not the finish line
where i need to learn where the finish
line is
oh no oh my word
that's this is the finish line this time
you can tell about the big face line
i'm very very upset about this right now
after all that time so that that's
called the speed car extreme that's what
that is
and uh yeah there was one other and he
beat me i'm very upset now
okay it can only be one and it wasn't
and it wasn't you
oh my word okay well we've got about 10
minutes left in the stream jan so
why don't you take us to one final
okay amazing race all right uh yeah so
and maybe maybe we need to create
another car i'm not sure let's see let's
see what race we've got
hey still got some decent money for that
abysmal performance
honestly if that was my job i would not
be married
well what i'll do don't worry to help
you i'll make sure i have some more tv
tech for you while you're driving you
need yeah need to
help you realize why you're doing so
well okay
what tutorials are giving us now uh we
don't need tutorials we've proven we're
expert drivers that's so funny my
partner's name is lionheart
really yeah his nickname uh
oh look at that beautiful beautiful work
of art it's not even a car it's a work i
really like the back of this car
honestly i don't think it looks that bad
it's just
the green and blue yeah it just kind of
through it
yeah okay okay let's try it yeah
yeah you may take out my beautiful car
return it return it in one piece
it's great
oh manhattan have you been to new york i
have
finally somewhere there we go yeah yeah
a few times i've been very lucky
um a couple of times with work nice and
one time on holiday okay actually i went
with seb
one time for work yeah yeah on his
birthday
you have some shenanigans no no it was
great fun it was it was just
amazing because uh yeah he was uh i
think he was hoping to
take his his his partner his now wife to
new york
to celebrate and then he ended up having
to go with me on his birthday
for work whoops okay so the serious now
you're in first so um oh it's just
university oh it's a head to head oh no
with lionheart oh it's meant to be going
down
okay um so actually i think i've
remembered
another um another feature of
the q800t that i hadn't mentioned and
that is
um it's got something called i know i
did mention this but i will tell you
again the dynamic black equalizer
which is is how the tv is part of the
game mode
the gamemode plus the game enhancer plus
sorry and
what it what it does is enable that
increased contrast
while while you're in game mode again
because the tv is capable of such a huge
range from highlights to shadows um
the yeah this this dynamic contrast it
lets you see more
in the kind of dark areas and enhances
those and it's not working
you're still in second come on i i i
don't this
this i don't know you've got this
i feel like i'm trying to actually kill
the driver by accident
rather than actually win the race is it
the fact that you're racing against your
partner is that i think i'm nervous now
yeah it's become personal
i love the story the camera angle for
where you're meant to be going
that was it you were just giving me
beautiful scenic views of the oh you
lost
beautiful scenic views of new york all
right shall i shall i give it a go
i think you know what it's best in your
hands i don't know about that i haven't
you won
once and uh you don't remember my last
race
with the insect oh yeah that's true yeah
you know what i really think it's this
car uh the patterns and what i won't
hear a blinding
hear anything against when i drive it is
amazing
have you been to manhattan before i have
i've got family in new york oh really
yeah i've been to manhattan um i've been
to quite a few places in america as well
um my favorite state is california
and i also like um i will say miami i
like miami i haven't been to the rest of
florida but i've been to a couple places
in california that i like
so i did like florida um
because it's like a huge caribbean
population there so i can
feel quite a home there but i did like
new york
um where else is called
been to boston i think you know um pax
east is in
boston it is yeah yes i've been there oh
really i've never been
yeah super cool it's huge such a huge
conference what up hey
wow that was doing well he zoomed past
you
okay come on gotta get serious lean
forward
come back here lionheart i've got chair
his car
is not a patch online is it okay if i
secretly root for him
well i will allow it but i will still be
upset
come on car oh no i took that corner so
badly
i mean
tell me more about u.s states that was
really helping me yeah okay
so i've been to new york virginia
washington dc
california boston
have you yeah you've been to washington
state that's my personal favorite
no oh it's beautiful so seattle
yeah i haven't been to seattle you gotta
go there it's really rainy there right
now
um it's not that bad it's like it's no
worse than the uk
and that's why i went going in fact it's
it's arguably better
okay i am i will never forget when i was
young
i went from the uk to new york
and it was raining in the uk and it was
raining in new york and i said to my nan
why am i here and i was only young
that's such a good question
just see first state there we go
there we go okay i think we probably
have time for one more quick
race all right cool
i'm gonna try and redeem myself and
while you're doing it i'll just i'll
just summarize
everything we've talked about today yeah
you know this combination that we've
created with the series x
and the q 800 t and that will drive you
to success
while you while you drive yeah to
success 100
you know what i really like about this
as well is i'm short-sighted but i
literally don't feel hindered
at all oh really yeah i can literally
see everything on the screen is so good
this it's funny because it's a great
size i feel like i'm we are actually
physically quite far away from the tv
but it's so huge
like 65 inch tv is it's not until you
sit in front of me like this you're like
yeah this is how i should be doing my tv
yeah it's so good
okay cool so you must be lionheart and i
will tell you more
so okay the things that we've learned
the reason why the q800t
is really good with the xbox series x if
you remember
first off 8k capable of 8k the console
is also capable of ak
it's not doing that yet though this is
helping i don't know
i'm trying well what if i told you more
things tell me if i told you about the
upscaling
yes yeah so um right now i mean because
again
technicalities we're seeing this at
1080p 60 but actually thanks to the
upscaling we're seeing this
at 1080p 4k upscaled and if you
were playing this at home with your
series xbox directly in
you'd be playing it at 4k upscale to 8k
when that and that if you remember that
upscaling is done
through artificial intelligence so ai
quantum processing and that phrase
which i've what was that what was my
favorite phrase uh deep learning
algorithms
yeah use these algorithms to figure out
where the pixels should be that aren't
there because of course it's creating
it's going from 4k to 8k or 1080p to 4k
and it's it's introducing those oh no
i'm obviously not doing a good job i'm
sorry because you're driving
is going downhill and yes of course
you've got the upscaling as well
come on jan you're almost there yeah i
mean oh there was the microphone i
didn't eat it
was holding you back okay didn't need
the bonnet
oh these poor people i'm sorry
send family flowers to your families i'm
sorry
oh come on you know you're there oh
chad's all gone horribly why is
what happened i don't it's this
lionheart you just
i just can't try i'm heartbroken i don't
know what's happened here
but yeah almost
i think well we've got we've got about
two minutes left on the stream so
can you finish you've got to get up yeah
it's right there you've got this you've
got this
okay come on it's right there i feel
like i'm driving
close feels like i'm driving the car and
only fools and horses oh my goodness
well wait unfortunately we didn't finish
on your
your best race but you you know but
second that was your best was good
yeah second out of two yeah well we
could say that
no one needs to know that it's all good
cool well i think
that is all the dirt we have time for on
the stream today
so everybody thank you so much for
watching i hope you have enjoyed seeing
you know the combination of the xbox
series x with the q800t
jan did you enjoy i did i enjoyed it
very much all my quad on all my
questions have been answered as well in
terms of what i need
because i just feel like if i get that
then everything else is
taken care of for the next gen anything
else that needs to be
that was released i'm already set it's
there i just think
yeah i think if what i do like about
this setup is you know that
no matter what they're to do with the
xbox series x and the ps5 over the next
few years in terms of unlocking things
like 8k
you can handle you know that you're
going to get you're going to get all
that stuff because you know what you
know whenever there's new functionality
you want
you want to know that you are you know
seeing it feeling it getting the
advantages of it and with the yeah the
q800 tur which is really cool
so if everyone watching at home um or
wherever you have me watching this
this is our first stream of three so
we're actually going to be back
for two more streams so one in two days
time yep
same time as well um so six o'clock in
the uk
yep which is 10 a.m
in america thank you thank you random
voice um
and pt of course west coast time and yes
and then the uh the third stream is
going to be a week on friday as well
which is the 11th of december at the
same time as well
what games are we playing and we're
going to be playing uh star wars
squadrons
yes and yeah i'm excited for fifa
because i play a lot of fifa and i
should be able to see the ball on this
tv is going to be great that's true
yeah so i'm a novice at fifa so you can
teach me that you've got time you've got
time
star wars squadrons that's my bad oh
really i've never played it okay let's
go
excellent ready so please do join us for
those hope you've enjoyed
and thanks very much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you